the media are just the propaganda arm of
of the liberal establishment and so
for instance
when gas jumps
an incredible amount over the past year
it's up i think what 56 or 57 percent
over the past year
and then it drops down
four to ten cents
an honest news media would come out and
say gosh gas is so high this is really a
big problem it's way way up but but
because the news media are not honest
because they're the propaganda arm of
the liberal establishment they go in
lock step with the exact same talking
points and say oh wow gas is down less
than 10 cents
huge win great news wonderful great
leader biden doing wonderful all praise
to biden
here at home americans are finally
getting some relief finally right
good news people we talk so much about
bad news oh my gosh
this is good news
gas prices are heading south down
government forecast forecast says that
they could drop
below
three dollars
a gallon
finally some economic relief however
minor americans are paying a little less
at the pump after weeks of rising energy
prices relief for the united states as
energy costs drop that pain that you've
been feeling to the pump it may be
short-lived there is finally some relief
at the pump good news at the pump
finally getting some relief as you
mentioned the national average price of
gas dropped four cents in the last week
gas dropped nearly a nickel in the last
week it's a seven week low it's moving
in the right direction the average is
now at a seven week low actually a seven
week low slightly lower gas prices so
that's good news yeah this is the kind
of positive news we've wanted really
good economic news including dropping
gas prices gas prices will tumble below
three dollars a gallon soon so that's
good news soon it's gonna happen soon
that's the news the news is a thing that
i'm predicting will happen in the future
because the news of what's actually
going on is so bad and devastating for
the liberal establishment that i can't
even report on that but in the future it
i bet it'll be better so that will be
good news
when that
when that happens my favorite one there
is gas prices down almost a nickel
wow really great news huh almost almost
a shiny nickel down the only one there
who even has the impulse to try to be
kind of honest is jake tapper but he's
still got to read all the talking points
because he still works for the corporate
media so he just goes gas prices are
down you know it's only a little big
mr zucker do i really have to okay i do
i guess i do because i'm i'm the
propaganda arm of the
liberal establishment
you like that show i'm glad now before
you go
i need you to ring that bell please
subscribe you'll get the notifications
probably the best way to do that head on
over to apple podcast spotify stitcher
google play wherever you get your audio
podcasts for free you can just subscribe
to the michael knoll show leave a five
star review we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]